[Musik]
etwas glaubt netz bekommen beim ein
video
irgendwie fühle ich mich hier noch ein
bisschen zu doll eingeengten diesen
ganzen bis zehn kinder schokolade hast
du genau was ich wollte gar nicht lange
reden alles cool
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich euch gibt einen hut wir
haben vom späten eintritt frei und 14
sekunden gerade auf jeden fall
es ist wieder spontan ich habe mich
jetzt einfach mal dazu entschlossen hier
zum video zu machen weil es in letzter
zeit
ich finde das so extrem und zwar bin ich
soweit einiger zeit single und seitdem
ich hier bin und das hat gewagt habe das
gar nicht mehr zusammen und so weiter
ich komme da nicht drauf klar ich weiß
nicht wie man so sein kann und was man
sich dabei denken kein klares weiß jeder
und man wird auch in der zuge von
darüber aufgeklärt die leute internet
ist nicht sicher und so aber in diesem
video geht es einfach mal um fake
account und ich möchte dazu gerne ein
paar sachen sagen weil es ist einfach so
krankheiten ist einfach krank dass es
keine ahnung solche menschen sollte man
schlagen egal ob die ok vielleicht jetzt
nicht wenn bis 14 ist okay wir beruhigen
und kultiger ich hab mir das ein paar
sachen aufgeschrieben
kurz nach schulen also heute fangen wir
mal ganz von vorn an
ich bin ja jetzt auch nicht mehr auf 15
oder 16 ich bin schon länger mit dem
internet intensiv in kontakt und benutze
es tagtäglich wirklich intensiv und
schmidt sagen ich gehöre schon so zu den
leuten die sicherheitskritische media
ganz besonders auskennen einfach weil
sie tagtäglich nutzen und ja ich habe ja
ne ganz ich weiß nicht ich das sagen
aber er versteht es erwischt und das
ding ist halt einfach mal das beispiel
also ich denke wirklich dass wenn man
nachricht oder relativ viele nachrichten
bei instagram oder snapshot oder sonstwo
und ich gucke mir öfter mal profile an
und wenn ich dann eine anfrage bekommen
oder mir schreibt irgendeine hey süßer
die 29 ist aussieht wie ein pornostar
erstmal um gesagt dann auch noch keine
ahnung 12 abonnenten hat und 1000
menschen folgt unter diesen 1000
menschen sind halt an die beauties fälle
da geht die irgendwelche berühmteren
social media menschen halt das ist halt
schon direkt ein hinweis darauf okay die
person ist locker fähig da sitzt
entweder ein zwölfjähriges
pubertierendes mädchen hinter oder ein
50-jähriger meinetwegen auch richtig
jähriger der gewisse naja die durchsagen
vorlieben hat ist ja so also ist ja kein
geheimnis dass ich im internet viele
komische menschen umtreiben als an sich
ich muss einmal auf dem profil gucken
zehn sekunden und kann schon sagen okay
das ist fähig oder das ist nicht völlig
klar da gibt auch unterschiede bei
manchen muss man mal genauer schauen ob
die auch freundin hat dima bilder
kommentieren oder sonst was ich denke
ihr versteht das also wird
wahrscheinlich meine ich will damit
sagen ich lasse mich schon ziemlich
intensiv damit auseinander wenn mir
jetzt vielleicht mädchen schreibers
schon älter ist und mir
äußerlich oder von ihren bildern her
gefällt dann schaue ich mal ob ich
antworte oder nicht aber gucken
merschformann das profil anja und darf
ich jetzt einfach mal so ein paar punkte
loswerden einfach um alle die mich zu
schauen oder generell alle die auch
etwas jünger sind oder sonst was ich
finde es wirklich so traurig es gibt so
viele fake account wie irgendwelche
kleinen mädchen abziehen oder ganz wahr
und will mit zwei service die ich
erzähle einfach mal ein bisschen zeigen
wie gefährlich das ist und dass sie
niemals vor allem wenn jetzt noch 12 614
mit einzelnen scheißegal die alte seite
aber schreibt niemals irgendwelche
fremden leuten die ihr gar nicht kennen
wo ihr euch auch nicht sicher sein ob es
die person wirklich gibt antwortete
niemals was euch niemals auch irgendwas
ein stück auch keinen vernehmliche fotos
von euch oder sonst was das ist das
allerwichtigste sagen ich fang mit
astoria die waren wirklich so ganz kann
das hat meine meine ansicht auf dieses
internet und diese fake account
geschichte nochmal einiges verändert und
ich habe mich wirklich so aufgeregt über
diese ok am ende haben julia und ich und
ich ziehe mich darüber amüsiert weil die
person dann plötzlich bericht ich den
schwanz eingezogen hat gleichwohl aber
folgendes ich bin halt einfach durch
meine insta direct messages gegangen und
hat ein bisschen rum geschaut und wenn
dann auch von profil gestoßen von
mädchen die meinte die wohl auch in köln
oder so und wir hatten haye hatte bock
mal was zu machen oder so und ich habe
mir gedacht ja herkommen kann zum
antworten keine ahnung vielleicht ist ja
ganz gut mir halt auch das profil so
angeschaut und das war wirklich ein
profil wirklich von dem ganz normalen
doch lieber 19 uhr so ganz normales
19-jähriges mädchen
hatte auch freundinnen wieder bilder
kommentieren hatte auch schon seit
eineinhalb jahren so instagram also da
man wirklich beiträge von anfang 2006
sind und ich dachte ja das kann auf
keinen fall den fake account beim die
hab ich sogar noch bei facebook edit und
hatte bei facebook auch ein account mit
500 freundin die kamera auch alle aus
der umgebung von köln ich dachte ja gut
war kann sich schon mal sicher sein dass
das niemand anderes übrig was du was ich
meine ich stets für mich in der
öffentlichkeit ich bin da ganz ganz
vorsichtig und ich schreibe niemandem
zurück wenn ich nicht weiß das ist
wirklich die person auf jeden fall haben
wir so ein bisschen bei instagram
geschrieben und irgendwann ganz ganz
offen sagen soll das bitte nicht traurig
wenn ihr 12 13 14 15 uhr sein und mich
mal vielleicht nach meiner website
nummer you preis ist nicht geantwortet
so auf jeden fall habe ich dann
irgendwann mit dem mädchen what's up ist
den geschrieben hat irgendwie habe ich
damals sprach gleich geschickt und ich
habe mich gewundert weil eigentlich zu
jeder normale mensch macht ja auch meine
sprachnachrichten schafft gegen wanne so
beschrieben hey warum machst du nie mehr
sprachlos und so kannst du auch eine
sprachlich machen und sie so nie mein
exfreund der hat immer so meinen
sprachnachrichten genommen und die so
anders zusammengeschnitten und da dachte
ich schon so was dass das verdankt er
seiner ich meine die hobby los muss man
sein um sowas zu machen aber ich habe
auch schon überlegt da hat er steckt
irgendwas anderes hinter meint das ist
doch kein argument dafür die meisten
aber schickte später ein und dann kam
irgendwann nicht seine normale
sprachnachricht sondern seine audio
wisst ihr da gibt es einen unterschied
gesehen ja dann so roth aus so genau das
hier ist eine audio ich weiß ja wie das
erkennen könnt aber und wenn man eine
ganz normale sprache macht dass er
komplett anders aus und das war einfach
eine audio die komplett auf dem kontext
worüber wir einzuschieben haben und ich
hab dann halbwegs sofort gesagt da gibt
bitte nicht du bist fake und weise für
eine nummer wie auch immer ich so dumm
sein konnte weil die hat ja wirklich so
normale freunde die das wahrheit
wirklich sonne verknüpfung auf fake
account er hat alle angegeben haben die
wohnen in köln oder in düsseldorf oder
sonst war und ich war wirklich so in dem
moment dachte mir so ein format und mein
mitbewohner also juli da kam dann auch
gleich darauf gleich dazu alter die
krank und an diese hinein springt kein
fake account bla bla bla und ich bin
dann immer so ich schreibe immer so was
plestan halten hat gesagt er ganz
ehrlich gesagt mir kopplin fake account
ist oder nicht dass ich meine connecten
spielen und lass deine nummer orten und
kann mir dann sagen ihm die gehörten
indes zu angezeigt blabla und dann kam
sein langer text das ganze schon jetzt
den herzlichen habe ich jetzt eigentlich
wenn ich habe nachgeschaut wo habt ihr
auch kopiert und gelöst und war auf
jeden fall stand dann irgendwie sonntags
bitte zeigt mich nicht an
ja ich gebe es zu ich bin viel klarer
war mit seiner scheiße und ich fand zeit
so krank wie ein mensch sich solche mühe
machen kann wirklich das war locker für
die person arbeit von sonst was sie
vielen hundert stunden das alles so
hinzubekommen diese ganzen account zu
erstellen das theorie lauf gewinnt das
geht sich mal eben so in zwei stunden
und so habe ich es musste erst mal sein
das war die erste story und so einig der
mit ausschlaggebende punkt dafür dass
ich gesagt habe egal wer die schreib
über internet oder sonst was jeder nicht
mehr darauf ein dass das kann wirklich
immerhin fähig sein so alles wirklich
dann sofort ist anziehend dem gegenüber
ok bis dann zeigt es doch wie folgt also
die erzähl ich jetzt habe ich ungefähr
vor einer woche habe ich bei snapshot
gepostet also wörtlich herauskommt wenn
ihr noch nicht gesehen habt übrigens
sehr cool einfach mal unbedingt wie die
beschreibung verlinkt könnt euch auf
jeden fall besser aus und zu habe ich
weiß herzlich gepostet dass ich so
medial suchen was wir achten jetzt
einfach aus rechtlichen gründen als ich
die fotos hat ohne probleme benutzen da
haben auf irgendwelchen homepage ist ich
hab so auch freundin und so in köln mit
dem schaft auch hätte machen können aber
ich hab mir so gelacht wenn irgendwer
von euch da draußen meine videos oder so
und daran wirklich bock hat und auch
keine ahnung cool moment kann also warum
nicht einfach nach und guckt was du so
bekommt daraufhin haben sich wirklich
viele mädels gemeldet so oft köln die
meisten wahrheit unter 18 arbeiten und
so 20 30 uhr so waren auch über und
eines nahezu voll ins auge stoßen und
die hat mir auch mega langen tag
gestiegen wie gern sie das machen würde
und wo die in köln wohnt und fanden sie
arbeiten muss und wann sie zeit hat und
so was alles und wir führen sie alles
von ge modeln hat hat er mir auch ein
paar bilder mit gestrickt und ich dachte
das wird toll passen nicht glaubt dass
wir cool aus und das war eigentlich
meine eigene dummheit weil ich habe ihr
profil einmal so angeschaut keine ahnung
hab mir das bild man schaut aber ich
habe jetzt nicht geguckt wem die folgt
wer alles da was leicht also was ist
natürlich immer wichtig um endlich
sicherstellen zu können
das ist gut so weil für mich diese
bewerbung wenn ich jetzt mal einfach so
total echt angehört hat und wer
kompletter ob idee mich an zu schreiben
oder unter diesem vorwand an zu
schreiben weil ich meine das ganze
tja so schnell wie möglich passieren und
muss sich ja dafür treffen und sie hat
sich halt dafür angeboten und sie war
nicht mal wieder keine ahnung auf jeden
fall habe ich ihren geschrieben jahre
der fotograf dafür da wird das gerne an
dem und dem tag machen dass zurzeit ja
habe ich privat ja okay wir haben so
auch noch ein bisschen weiter
geschrieben mit anderen dinge heißt wir
hatten auch sprach lassen und so was
geschickt das ding behalten nur es war
ein mädchen aber ist warnt das mädchen
das auf diesen fotos watt und zwei
stunden bevor hat dann dieses
fotoshooting stattfindet hat die heute
sagt er ich kann leider nicht ich bin
müde oder so und ich dachte hey du bist
müde und deswegen kannst mich dein ernst
grad ich meine ich habe dir von
vornherein gesagt dass an dem tag und
ich darf 75 das cool oder willst du
unbedingt mitmachen und wirklich erst
dann habe ich mal ihr instagram profil
ein bisschen genauer angeschaut und hast
du gemerkt hätte dass er gemacht auch
wirklich von fake account den es seit
zwei jahren gibt der seit zwei jahren
aktiv fotos von irgend einem anderen
mädchen hochwahrscheinlich amerika oder
wand warf und sicherheit als diese
person ausgeübt und das verdammt gut
markt außerhalb dass sie keine freundin
hat die man bilder kommentieren oder so
das ganze profil hat halt kaum
kommentaren so was alles und da hatte
ich dann halt auch ausgestellt ist das
ein fake war und seitdem für nicht
glücklich ich bin wirklich geschockt und
ich denke mir was gibt es für kranke
menschen und spaß sollte man alle in die
fresse hauen egal wie alt seid nicht ob
das jetzt war überhaupt nicht klar für
mich frage warum man so sein muss oder
wieso man das macht aber ganz ehrlich es
gibt so viele 14 15 jährigen habe ich
eben schon gesagt die sich darauf dann
was einbilden die sich vielleicht sogar
in diesen charakter verlieben das ist ja
auch schon wissenschaftlich bewiesen
dass man sich sogar über das treiben
schon verlieben kann l und ich verstehe
nicht wie man das so aus los bekannt und
wie man so aktiv da sein kann und wie
man sucht daraus sein kann sich einfach
als eine andere person auszugeben so
weil man selber nicht mit sich zufrieden
ist oder irgendwelche pädophilen
vorlieben hat oder sonst hast keine
ahnung und deswegen das muss ich jetzt
einfach mal sagen ich wollte euch
hiermit nur sagen passt wirklich darauf
mit wem er schreibt was ihr schreibt was
sie für sachen schlägt und sonst was das
internet ist ein sehr gefährlicher ort
vor allem auch für jüngere deswegen wenn
eure eltern mit zwölf oder 13 ab und zu
mal euer handy
kontrollieren sei nicht böse oder so das
ist absolut richtig und das würde ich
glaube ich auch machen wenn ich jetzt
vater nicht fragt als wenn ich
irgendwann mal ein sohn oder tochter
habt dann ist es wirklich wichtig dass
man dabei auch wenn die städte nicht
böse doch mir seid dann auf jeden fall
dankbar dafür dass sie das machen und
das sie interessiert was er schreibt ja
heute wird man ab ich würd ich mir
darüber noch nach oben freuen
hier könnt ihr noch snitil renz
abstecken wir sind ansonsten samstag
oder sonntag wieder keine ahnung
haut rein